bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors les tribunaux ont à ce jour
condamnés près de 4500 personnes
infligeant des peines de prison à vie à
près de 3000 d'entre elles selon les
chiffres officiels quatre ans procès à
charge c'est ce que dénoncent les
proches des combats des condamnés on les
a entendu tout à l'heure quel est votre
regard sur le déroulé de ces quatre
années de procès justement alors à
propos du coup d'état du 15 juillet 2016
il faudrait attendre le coup trois
légendes urbaines autour de ces de ces
événements la première c'est que
certains pensent qu'il s'agissait d'un
d'un coup d'état mené par des kémalistes
contre des islamistes il faut savoir que
depuis une trentaine d'années des
canelles kémaliste n'était plus
représenté dans l'appareil militaire
comme il l'avait été dans les décennies
précédentes
pour la simple raison que les officiers
de l'armée avait déjà été approché par
le réseau gulen que l'islamisation de
l'appareil militaire est un processus
qui dure depuis les années 70 et donc il
faut bien comprendre que le coup d'état
militaire est en fait un coup de force
et à une confrontation entre deux
franges conservatrices de l'élite turque
que ce qu'on voit aussi c'est que il n'y
a pas eu un mais deux coups d'état parce
qu'il ya eu dans un premier temps les
réguler haine qui ont essayé de prendre
le pouvoir par la force mais dès le
lendemain le régime à doan s'est servi
comme prétexte de ce coup d'état pour
régler ses comptes à tous et aux
opposants et donc on a vu que dans
l'après coup d'état il y a eu des purges
massives qui ont touché près de 150
travailleurs de la fonction publique et
dans le cadre de ces curieuses enfin des
gens qui n'avaient absolument rien à
voir avec le coup d'état ni avec le
réseau bus l'aisne se sont retrouvés à
la rue marginalisée pointé du doigt
criminalisés voire emprisonner et donc
en fait trop j'ai il y a donc ce procès
qui aura duré quatre années commun les
échanges se sont déroulés alors dans un
premier temps le régime ces attaques
--essentiellement
menu fretin des gens qui par exemple
étaient simplement des étudiants dans un
internat qui était plus ou moins liés au
réseau ghislaine il ya eu par exemple
des épargnants d'une banque qui était
labellisés comme étant gül à nice par
contre les gens qui ont coupé le ruban
pour inaugurer cette banque se retrouve
du côté des douanes tout ça pour dire
qu'en fait on ne comprend pas trop ce
qui passe ce qui se passe dans les
arcanes du pouvoir parce qu'il s'agit
essentiellement d'une confrontation
entre des gens qui se connaissent très
bien
il ya quelques années encore on ne
savait pas qui était en fait les gi les
listes et les airs d'organiste c'était à
peu près la même chose pour le commun
des mortels et l'opposition historique
constate et suit celle cette histoire
avec avec beaucoup d'incompréhension et
subit en fait les autres de et la
vengeance du régime parce que on se rend
compte de plus en plus que qu'un grand
nombre de cuves et nice se retrouve
aujourd'hui au pouvoir
ceux qui hier encore à du lait est
présenté comment dire le rejet fendi
comme ils disent le vénérable maître
c'est à dire c'est tout et à geleen
comme leur leader se retrouvent
aujourd'hui à le conspuer
donc on comprend pas trop quand on est
du point de vue de l'opposition civile
historique
on comprend pas ce qui se passe parce
que c'est vraiment une minute c'est au
tour de gaël games of thrones à la tour
cas si j'ai pu dire les détracteurs du
président r douanes pointent du doigt
l'absence de contrôle parlementaire il
n'y aurait plus d'état de droit en
turquie quel est votre votre wii en
europe en juin alors d'abord il ya eu un
des purges au sein de la magistrature
plus de 2000 procureurs et juges ont été
exclues de leur profession ensuite il ya
eu la nomination par le régime
directement de certains juges qui ont
joué le rôle de torquemada donc de deux
juges
si vous voulez qu'ils à l'équipe qui
avait comme mission de criminaliser les
opposants à hugo n'est donc on n'était
plus là a à juger des actes mais plutôt
des opinions est très vite
en fait ce qui ressemblait à une
confrontation entre les guinées nist et
les airs d'organiste s'est transformé en
une en une purge visant tout ce qui
était entière de gan quelques
qu'ils aient pu être leur sensibilité
politique et donc il ya une politisation
de l'appareil judiciaire comme on n'a
jamais vu il ya eu un élargissement de
la définition même du concept de
terrorisme
c'est ainsi qu'on a retrouvé des gens
qui n'ont absolument rien à voir ni avec
une lutte armée quelconque n'y avait
qu'une un engagement politique et le
compte des gens simples des étudiants
d'aidé mis des militaires qui venaient
d'être de gagner leur diplôme et qui se
sont retrouvés derrière les barreaux
pendant ce temps le régime a continué à
régner en maître absolu sur le sur
l'état merci beaucoup au bar king où
j'en appelle cause est le journaliste
indépendant merci